dans le village dandy macabou sur l'île
malgache de nocibé rares sont les
habitants à avoir échappé à la récente
épidémie de fièvre un moment donné d'un
coup tout le monde a été atteint par la
fièvre il n'y avait pas de docteur pour
expliquer si c'était tel ou telle
maladie pour faire descendre la
température on a fait des inhalations de
quinine c'est tout ce qu'on a
voir la décoction et se laver avec et
depuis ça va
cette épidémie aurait pu faire croire à
l'arrivée du coronavirus dans le village
mais elle a démarré en février un mois
avant l'arrivée du coc vite 19 à
madagascar
pas de docteur dans ce village de
pêcheurs
accessible uniquement par la mer mais
une infirmière pour veiller sur la santé
de plusieurs centaines d'âmes pour
nazaire banggai en poste ici depuis 27
ans cela ne fait aucun doute c'est la
dengue qui a provoqué cette hécatombe
une maladie transmise par le moustique
tigre extrêmement répandu dans la zone
océan indien actuellement la dengue
affecté 300 habitants du village 115
personnes au mois de mars 98 au mois
d'avril et une centaine le premier mois
ça fait bien trois cents habitants
touchés les plus âgés n'ont pas été
épargnés mais aucun décès n'est à
déplorer 6 à tuer il n'y aurait plus
personne dans ce village
à 78 ans ernestine est encore affaiblie
je vais plus me lever
je n'ai pas mangé pendant 15 jours pour
le coronavirus les symptômes sont la
fièvre la toux ou des difficultés
respiratoires alors que pour la dengue
on constate une très forte fièvre pas de
tout pas de difficultés respiratoires
alors que la crise sanitaire mondiale a
jusque là épargné ce village des
affiches de prévention sur le co vite 19
sont placardées partout
pas de campagne par contre sur les
épidémies qui sévissent ici
depuis peu c'est le palu qui prend le
relais la fièvre pas lui
le paludisme est également transmis par
les moustiques femelles mais de type
anophèles c'est l'un des fléaux
sanitaires les plus meurtriers la
pandémie de covin 19 perturbe les
campagnes de prévention mais également
le dépistage menée en partie par des
organisations médicales étrangères comme
l'association française armada
ces activités sont suspendues depuis la
fermeture des frontières
ces images tournées lors de l'une des
dernières missions sur le fleuve thiery
been à l'ouest de madagascar montre
l'importance du diagnostic dans ce
désert médical depuis le mois de mars
les populations de cette région n'y ont
plus accès alors que l'épidémie est loin
d'être maîtrisée le dernier rapport de
l'oms indiqué que madagascar fait partie
des dix pays en afrique là où on a noté
un recul d'un terme de lutte conte
paludisme il faut pas se voiler la face
comme un certain nombre de pays en
afrique il ya des moments où nous sommes
confrontés à des problèmes de ressources
de ressources financières et qui fait
qu' on n'a pas à temps ce dont on a
besoin
un intrant ce soit un médicament ou un
outil de diagnostic
dans ce contexte où les moyens de lutte
se focalise sur le coronavirus le nombre
de décès causés par la malaria en
afrique subsaharienne pourrait doubler
pour atteindre 760 9000 morts cette
année selon l'organisation mondiale de
la santé
[Musique]